well Russell is going to come check you
out man I can't let you go you were
literally choking in your sleep somebody
flagged me down about it I have sleep
apnea I'm sorry well you know you have a
crack pipe in your hands A city
councilman in Cranston Rhode Island
faces a drug charge after a police
officer finds him sleeping in his car
with a crack pipe in his hand thanks for
joining us here on Law and crime I'm
Anjanette Levy that Cranston police
officer's body camera recorded the
interaction he had with councilman
Matthew Reilly earlier this week take a
look you can see Riley sleeping his
mouth wide open as the officer
approaches Riley has a lighter and a
pipe in his hand the officer Rouses him
from his sleep do you have any weapons
no not at all
because
[Applause]
all right roads open
oh no way dude really yes yes I was just
taking I was on my way back from Court
well arrested's gonna come check you out
man I can't let you go you were
literally choking in your sleep somebody
flagged me down about it I have sleep
apnea I'm sorry well and then you have a
crack pipe in your hands so it's like
wait sorry listen I I have a body camera
obviously yeah I think I have it's
recorded you know that and what I've
observed it's on camera so I can't
pretend I didn't you know so a Russia's
gonna come here and if they're going to
check you out you know as far as I know
there's no drugs anywhere so I know you
know so there's not a criminal
investigation there's more Health
well-being check thank you
um but uh yeah I obviously have to
document it you know
they can have that back thank you
so we'll be no rest what there will be
no rest no
um is there any are there any drugs in
the car or anything like that no no
nothing all right the officer questions
Riley about his drug use he's
forthcoming and discusses struggling
with addiction how long have you had
this problem man it was a it was a
relapse I've been clean for 13 years
all right
I just went through a really really bad
divorce recently okay
um
uh do you know if any of that was laced
with fentanyl or anything because you
were out out and like looked like you
were choking really yeah that's why
someone literally sprinted and flagged
me down because they thought you were
having a heart attack or choking uh no
not that I know
EMTs arrived to check out Riley as the
police officer searched his vehicle
which is littered with trash and junk
the officer found a chore boy scouring
pad in the glove box Troy boy is made of
copper and metal drug users sometimes
use a chore boy to make a crack pipe you
got a test kit yeah
so um
officer arrives they approach
the vehicle to test suspected drugs
found in the car what's wrong with this
guy
so you don't know him at all you guys
don't know I've never met him in my life
I'm probably dig out just a smaller
Little Rock so we don't have to break
anything uh if you get a little bit
the powder yeah
yeah it's kind of awkward
be careful because he was on the nod or
like it seems like anyways it's mixed
with something else but
all right
do you need this knife
yeah
be careful with that stuff is I don't
know if that's fentanyl waste or not
there's white oil over there he doesn't
know yeah I was just telling him the
same thing because I mean you don't fall
asleep he usually comes completely
yeah
he claims he was tied and he may have
sleep apnea but I don't think that's
gonna
fly especially like this yeah
yeah only climb a lot too it's like you
stick out like a sore thumb
well right away
fentanyl oh cool crack perfect back I
didn't test it for fan while dress up a
boat just to make sure that I don't know
what we're dealing with can you just
snap a picture of that especially we're
going to put him in a Cell the sergeant
on scene tells the officers to charge
Riley then they look at a white powder
on his driver's seat let's have his
mother come get the car but I'm not
gonna no I'm not getting any of touch
and all that all that white powder is
that that's correct yeah yeah that's
definitely that's definitely correct
yeah yeah most likely
yeah you can smell it and he's burning
up he has a bunch of Toy Boy and should
we have it towed
half living out of us we're good we're
on private property
yeah look at this
it's not a problem
I'll do all the uh evidence stuff
thank you all right so um
they're just finishing up right now okay
he's got the Bro on everything over
there you see it yeah
the first officer on scene also removed
a crack pipe from Riley's vehicle Riley
appears to be okay after leaving EMTs
and talking to the officer yeah I know
it's not like
have an option here man sorry
[Music]
oh uh
all right there's stuff all over that
car and your mother gets in that golf I
bet she sits in that and touches her
face her mouth and goes down I have no
idea
yeah you don't know you buy him
did you buy that today yesterday yeah
you know it's the same guy you usually
buy it from
anyway
they're not all honest
no I mean I mean
once or twice Yeah but whether you buy
it from with you if you continuously buy
it from them you know who you're buying
it from this you don't know what people
are putting in it no I I understand you
know they may have made that person so
that's a big rock you got in there
what's that a 50 piece
100 yeah so I just just got back into
this this is gonna listen I this is
terrible situation we're all in a tough
spot but we gotta do it we got to do
right by the Numbers it'll help you in
the end
and you'll say to us a month from now
good best thing that ever happened to me
yesterday you can't go down this road
anymore no no
that that would that's terrible you know
what I mean you were down in the car no
I don't know yeah
you just you gotta get on a program
right away I mean I look at you you're
not that Matt Riley that we know trust
me
listen your health and your well-being
is worth way more
than any political career Riley then
expresses his concern about the media
finding out about his arrest
we don't report nothing to the media
unless someone tells them so and then
arrest records our public record I'm not
going to like you
kids
there's not much we can do on this and
for if I was in your situation I'd be in
handcuffs no no I'm not saying oh I'm
not saying don't rest yeah yeah yeah in
terms of media for kids as much yeah no
listen we are only required to release
what we release and we won't
we have to release an arrest record by
law you know
all right jump in before you
just want to make sure we're going to
monitor you because yeah
and that's that's you know we've got to
make sure you're
you know may not feel it right now but
God forbid something happens to you yeah
no I've never done that it's horrible
about that you know
I mean you're not going to be there all
day you'll be in it all I'm Gonna Keep
your wallet with me I have your phone
already you want me to throw this stuff
in the car real quick all right
step on it here I'll buckle you up
oh wait yeah
who's gonna come get this car after
I would huh
it is
getting fixed oh this isn't even your
car no it's all right
all right
I mean this there's all on the seat
yeah I mean I was a joke I have an
appointment on out of 17. all right I'll
crack a window for you in a second
Matthew Riley faces a drug possession
charge he's resigned from his position
as chairman of cranston's Republican
party and he's in rehab the mayor of the
city has urged him to step down from
city council and he's done so publicly
Riley will be back in court next month
for Law and crime I'm Anjanette Levy